[Música]
el alquiler de vientres es una práctica
muy usada por extranjeros en países como
Colombia donde pagan menos o por
gestaciones subrogadas que además no
están reguladas y hacen fácil el
desarrollo de actividades criminales
alrededor de este negocio que ya ha sido
considerado como violatorio de Derechos
Humanos en otros países vamos al
análisis de este tema con María Cristina
Hurtado quien es abogada y politóloga
feminista magíster en políticas públicas
ex defensora del pueblo para derechos de
la infancia y mujeres y docente e
investigadora consultora independiente
Muchísimas gracias bienvenida a María
Cristina a directo a América Muchísimas
gracias Ángel pero el tema que nos llama
el día de hoy no es para nada fácil ni
agradable que prácticas asociadas a los
alquileres de vientre han podido
identificar ustedes
Bueno yo creo que ante todo Estamos
hablando de los efectos de un mercado
global sí de un mercado global que ha
convertido el cuerpo de las mujeres y el
cuerpo de los niños y de las niñas en
mercancías transables de hecho la
propuesta que presenta el gobierno para
reglamentar esta práctica pues habla de
comitente y comitentes la persona que
casi siempre viene de países
desarrollados donde está prohibida la
práctica como Italia como Francia
como España donde el movimiento social
de mujeres dio una pelea muy grande
igual en Francia
como Italia y en esta medida se estas
connacionales se vienen a Colombia a
hacer este tipo de prácticas en razón
Aunque su país está
prohibido tal vez de las cuestiones más
letales es que hay mercados negros
mercados oscuros en todo el mundo
asociados a esta práctica que han
convertido el cuerpo de las mujeres
Precisamente en esto en negocios y de
hecho el proyecto que presenta el
gobierno en este momento Un gobierno de
izquierda que prometió a las mujeres y a
los niños una vida mejor el proyecto
está hablando precisamente de un
comitente que desde el punto de vista
del Derecho civil que es el derecho de
las cosas de los bienes de la república
más No desde el punto de vista de los
Derechos Humanos que es por lo que hemos
peleado que son los derechos más humanos
particularmente cuando recaen sobre
mujeres niños y niñas que en el caso
colombiano tienen un Amparo
constitucional legal y de todas las
convenciones internacionales entonces
la mayoría de las mujeres que se prestan
este tipo de prácticas son mujeres
empobrecidas
excluidas socialmente de los beneficios
del desarrollo Pero además
son mujeres que
están con una narrativa que viene
principalmente de parte de los
intermediarios de las clínicas donde se
hacen estos procedimientos donde Estas
mujeres se ven muchas veces obligadas a
una narrativa de altruismo
donde esta práctica que implica llevar
en su vientre por nueve meses a un niño
o una niña y luego entregarlo a ese
comitente
pues se plantea como una práctica
altruista y generosa que se hace por un
tercero yo misma estoy invitada por los
dos ministerios tanto por el de salud
como el de Justicia cuando se presentó
el proyecto de ley y tuve que oír a
varias de estas madres colombianas Y
pues la narrativa es yo me puse en el
lugar de estos papitos europeos Sí y
logré darles la felicidad entregarles Un
niño Entonces yo creo que de nuevo se
está haciendo se está recogiendo ese
lenguaje manido de que las mujeres
estamos en capacidad de entregarlo todo
de darlo todo cuando realmente la
mayoría de mujeres empobrecidas en todo
el planeta acceden a esta práctica como
una forma de sobrevivencia Bueno Este es
un lobby que no es nuevo ni en Colombia
ni en ningún país del mundo y es una
discusión que está muy activa en las
legislaciones seguramente usted está al
tanto de la denuncia que hace la ong
valientes que pide que se regule esta
causa en qué sentido bueno eso habría
que verlo pero también hace unas
denuncias que son bien preocupantes y de
las cuales no existen cifras porque el
tema no se investiga entonces además de
la práctica irregular de adopciones de
niños si se puede decir de esta manera o
o partos a través de madres que prestan
su vientre pues está la denuncia de que
estos bebés eventualmente pueden o son
utilizados para explotación sexual y
además está la denuncia de que estos
bebés son utilizados para el tráfico de
órganos entonces estas son declaraciones
aterradoras denuncias aterradoras que no
tenemos como verificar que no tenemos
como evaluar porque simplemente no
existe legalmente como atajar estas
prácticas mire
[Música]
en esta práctica puede ser o regulada o
considerada regulada Y altruista sí o
prohibida o simplemente dejar que el
mercado hable que es como se da en
Estados Unidos en Rusia en Bielorrusia
puede ir en ambas vías no es decir está
algo en la ley que se pronuncia acerca
de es o no Es legal no partamos de ahí
pero qué pasa entonces con las denuncias
Sí mire yo creo que tenemos una ventaja
comparativa nosotros los colombianos y
colombianas Y es que como esto es un
mercado global hemos visto los efectos
desastrosos de la práctica en Rusia en
Bielorrusia en Ucrania donde los niños y
las niñas productos de estas prácticas
cuando no satisfacen las necesidades de
quienes los están comprando son
abandonados
las mujeres por ejemplo tienen que
someterse a tratamientos muy grande muy
complicados
con hormonas con
antibióticos
pierden su movilidad su libertad sí Y
muchas mujeres pierden también la vida a
través de la práctica entonces no es que
no esté documentado mercado negro hay en
Checoslovaquia sí que lo tiene
reglamentado o sea reglamentar no
implica que el mercado negro vaya a
desaparecer también lo tiene Grecia y
Grecia se ha convertido en la puerta de
entrada de un negocio multinacional
alrededor de la vida y de la dignidad de
estas mujeres y la dignidad de estas
mujeres y niñas ya nos estamos quedando
sin tiempo así que le pido ser breves
hablemos de los efectos emocionales de
una mujer que presta su vientre sea por
dinero o sea por altruismo como se dice
muchas veces para parir a un bebé que no
va a ser de ella
mire
lo primero que se rompe sí a través de
las narrativas de las clínicas y los
intermediarios es la relación afectiva
entre la mujer y el niño que va a nacer
está absolutamente demostrado por
estudios bioéticos que las mujeres
en el embarazo
desarrollamos vínculos vínculos
afectivos vínculos químicos vínculos
biológicos que separar a un a un bebé de
su madre y entregárselo a unos terceros
desconocidos
trae consecuencias en la psique de estos
niños pero también en la psique de las
mujeres también es así que lo que hacen
estas clínicas es posteriormente darle
asistencia psicológica y psiquiátrica a
estas mujeres es uno de los actos más
violentos que pueda haber además de que
viene precedido de un contrato donde la
mujer pierde Sí hasta la filiación no
tiene la posibilidad de tener ningún
vínculo con ese niño y se pierde la
afiliación
Pues bien nos queda claro no somos
vasijas Este es un tema del que se
seguirá hablando en Colombia en América
Latina y por supuesto en otras partes
del mundo tenemos algunos referentes
como España y ojalá podamos ver hacia
allá para entender qué han hecho otros y
si ha funcionado en esos países Yo le
agradezco mucho a usted por su tiempo y
por entregarnos una visión más amplia de
lo que es este mercado que existe
alrededor del alquiler de vientres y
mercado no eso ya es una palabra
bastante fuerte ese María Cristina
Hurtado abogada y politóloga feminista
magíster en políticas públicas y ex
defensora del pueblo para los derechos
de la infancia y de las mujeres Gracias
a usted a nuestros televidentes se sigan
en directo a América de France 24 y ya
volvemos con más